I got a question before we go here Conan
have you ever been mad at Bob Dylan
because I'm furious is Bob I'm furious
at Bob Dylan right why cuz you know he
did that 17 minute JFK song in response
to the coronavirus well I thought it
would be a perfectly lovely thing to do
a song parody of subterranean homesick
blues yeah and and one of my head
writers wrote a really funny parody of
it and they have said Dylan say did no
uncertain certain terms you may not do
that neutron bomb with a lawsuit and I
just don't think that's nice how old is
that song he's gotten all the juice he's
gonna get out of that Old Stone come on
let the rest of us have a crack at it I
have won Bob Dylan story which is a
bunch of years ago I went to my a Bob
Dylan concert and it was before the show
and my good friend and guitarist Jimmy
Vivino said do you want to meet Bob and
I said I'm not ready to meet Bob and he
went let's go and I got shoved into a
room and suddenly people parted and I
was face to face with Bob Dylan and it
was when he had that little mustache
sure a little like a villain and he
looked at me and I said oh uh hello mr.
Dylan and he went I know you from the TV
and just then I was whisked out of the
room and that was my only contact with
Bob Dylan I know you from the TV he said
it just like that that sounds like the
beginning of a pretty good song actually
it should be one of his songs what are
you doing now I just want to give you a
taste of what America whenever here yeah
okay we're all in the basement wishing
for some medicine I'm isolating
recommended by the government the man in
the cheap gloves GrubHub day job says
he's got a bad cough wants to get a test
swab come on I understand that song
parody is the lowest form of human
entertainment but that's damn fine
listen to the end here I don't want to
virus sales you better Purell the Trump
don't work cuz the foul she makes him
grouchy come on Bob so you're you good
heal a nation no no you'd have a lot of
young people who didn't know what you
were talking about it's got to be a
cardi B song you've got it all I
wouldn't I'm on CBS Conan it's got to be
do
Lipa you know you gotta bring it up you
can't be saying hey kids it's time I
took down Bob Dylan that's I'm not
taking them down I'm celebrating Bob
Dylan okay yeah why are you yelling at
me I don't know you're a long way I'm
angry I'm angry at Bob Dylan I'm sorry
and you've got a guitar over your
shoulder and I don't know I just I'm not
being fair to you when I apologize Conan
are you crying now you look like you're
crying
you